how much do you pay for rent in New York
687 no way yeah you want to come see 95
square feet of pure happiness the whole
Space huge window makes this apartment
it opens up you know I write my letters
and bills here dude I like this setup
actually right up there I actually love
that I like that setup I love that
everything in one spot if you're a
single guy you're a single gal there's
so little utility in wasting money like
I would rather live in a better area in
a tiny little place than in a worse area
in a bigger spot he has all of his needs
that he's looking for when I was in
Paris I actually lived in a spot that
was about the same size as that for
three months and uh it didn't affect my
experience at all